very exciting not only 10 years of
sister wives
10 seasons of sister wives what are you
most excited for fans
to get into with your family we are
basically pouring out our feelings
and in doing so we're in relationships
we're trying to be honest about how we
feel and so it's kind of a
he said she said and
a mixture of that um it's not easy to
watch it
and it's not exciting to me
i'm sorry that that's no that's okay
listen i understand
especially with the trailer that i've
watched it's a tough season
uh there seems to be a little bit of
trouble in paradise
and everybody is wondering how
cody's relationship with each of the
wives
is are they gonna make it so if i may
i'd love to kind of go down the list and
ask you about
each of your wives uh let's start with
with wife number one let's start with
mary
cody and mary's relationship is really
sad
i can't i can't make him love me so if i
were to lean over and just kiss you
right now
would you push me away um no
how was your relationship with mary
today mary and i are in an amiable
relationship but we've been like
literally separated for
i would say four or five years so we're
we're amiable we've had a real struggle
and this year we have some very
difficult conversations
but that in conversation includes
hey i'm not mad anymore i'm not
angry anymore i'm not hurt anymore
so you know that's real progress romance
and sex are saved
for people who are in love
if mary and i really wanted to be
together we would
can you just kind of explain what your
relationship with mary
is because you said you've been
separated for four or five years but
she's still
according to the show is a sister wife
she's still my wife we
we just have not i haven't lived at her
house
for four years so i i understand you
don't live there do you ever go
stay the night do you what do you reside
forever yeah
we're really careful about talking about
bedrooms but
mary and i um i i we
we see each other on a fairly regular
basis we visit with each other that type
of stuff
but we're i'm not staying at her house
we've been trying to basically
work out our relationship so we can save
it if you will
it's a estranged marriage it's it's a
marriage
that needs to work out some stuff okay
let's move on to wife number two janelle
maybe there are some of us who are like
look i don't want it anymore
where do you and janelle stand today
janelle and i uh i think are in good
place
um covid has put a real strain
on our time together but we've survived
times like this in the past there's no
trouble in paradise if you will next
time i see cody
i'm going to tell him i freaking want to
move back to utah even though the girls
don't want to
how would you describe your relationship
with christine today
christina and i have a really fun
experience this year as we go
celebrate our anniversary we've had some
misunderstandings because of kovid
plural marriage to put a little little
more pressure on our relationship and
um so it's like hey if you're not over
it's because you don't like me
uh no if i'm not over it's because you
didn't follow
covid protocols and so now we're going
to
wait until the coast is clear basically
i'm just going to be frank here i'm like
a stepmom
how is everything going with robin are
you guys currently living together
i see robin regularly because there's no
been no quarantining for robin because
she's done no travel
but um it's just the only thing is as
life is a little bit more boring
uh we're struggling with helping small
children
do online school are there plans to
expand the family
we are not adding wives and most likely
not ever
having children but adoption is not not
out of the out of the realm
here you know i hope it's not a spoiler
but i don't think i'm having any more
kids
there's rumors online that you've added
a fifth wife how do you respond to that
that's that's a rumor that they just
like throwing out there they
they they're so gross with some of the
um tabloids there will never be a fifth
wife
we've had to be in four separate homes
i'm very worried because it looks like
it's gonna even be more separation
i think now is the time for us to make a
plan on what we're going to do at coyote
pass
so can i ask you where you're currently
living and and how does it work with
you know a schedule because i've not
been staying at mary's house it's been a
three house rotational schedule
so it's every three days or every six
days so we're currently
just doing the rotation depending on if
somebody's traveling or somebody's
getting exposure
where do things stand on living together
is coyote past going to happen yes
however we will
never be building one house okay but
that's not one roof
no it's not one roof it'll be it'll be
uh four lots four homes
is that what you want what's your
preference well um
i don't want to give any season spoilers
but i start to motivate everything so
i'm going to look for five lots
and five homes the house that i built on
my lot would be either a guest house
uh a house that our children our adult
children can
live in or visit in well speaking of
your adult children
i know that not not everybody is dating
or quite at the age
quite yet but the adult children the
ones who are of age
uh none of them are in plural
relationships or plural marriages so
i'm curious as a father uh do you
encourage
your kids to lean one way or another
maybe more so
in the past now i try not to meddle
um at all but i don't really
not really advocating that they'd be in
plural marriage
or not i i see something that they would
work out with their spouse
but this isn't um this isn't kind of a
this if i if i was deeply embedded in my
religion in
utah it might be kind of a legacy
lifestyle
if that were the case but it's not one
two three four wives said
no we're never moving back to utah
maybe the drama problem in our lives is
me 10 years of sister wives
10 seasons how will you know
when it's time to call it a day and tell
the cameras to go home
when the viewers stop enjoying the show
it's it's a fatiguing prospect
i mean i am sitting down on the couch
pouring my guts out
to you and so as long as that still
works the american people
don't just go dude you're grossing us
out so bad we can't
you know until i've offended the whole
world
do you see that do you read comments
that are you know not very favorable
oh no it's not my business what you
think about me when you think back
on 10 years of sister wives what is your
absolute
favorite moment that you love to revisit
and go back to
and what is the one moment that you wish
didn't exist or that cameras at least
weren't there to capture
there are so many moments that i wish
the camera weren't there
the most recent one is is a couple of
years ago mary and i went and uh to do
some
counseling with our marriage counselor
nancy hunterton in las vegas we left
flagstaff to go do that
and on the trip there of the
conversation had gone something that
triggered in me and i was a
brute to her in our session and i wish
that i
wouldn't have had that film you know i i
feel like there are things that need to
be saved
but boy that's that's a lot to put on
the shoulders of a person
and make them accountable to all of the
american public
so um that that's that's there's a lot
of those mistakes
that we have that were really tough i'll
say one of the highlights for me of the
entire show was probably when when
solomon was born
because i i thought that was a really
really sweet experience
you